et bien bonjour monsieur bonjour
monsieur bonjour monsieur et joyeuses
fêtes monsieur et joyeuses fêtes
monsieur et voilà voilà
[Rires]
très bien la preuve que vous êtes
voyante c'est que vous êtes venu ici ah
c'est quoi ça ce que vous me donnez il
faut que j'ouvre
c'est secret au secret dans l'isolement
d'accord elle est bourrée la dame non
Daisy va-t-elle porter chance à l'équipe
de France le chien de l'ambassade des
États-Unis à Paris en tout cas choisi la
gamelle de la victoire et elle est bleue
blanc rouge
et que demain l'équipe de France comment
on est samedi soir
[Applaudissements]
l'équipementier officiel des Bleus
semble très optimiste par rapport aux
résultats du match de demain et il a
pris beaucoup d'avance car oui sur son
site internet Nike a mis en vente hier
un maillot des Bleus avec trois étoiles
avant de finalement se rendre compte de
l'erreur est-ce qu'on gagne la finale
demain après-midi est-ce qu'on gagne
cette finale bah bien entendu
[Applaudissements]
l'aéroport de Nice a lui annoncé un vol
vers la troisième étoile décollage prévu
à 16h les derniers supporters français
se sont eux envolés cette nuit pour le
Qatar
et ils se sont bien échauffés la voix et
oui il faut que
3h30 je crois que c'est la norme il faut
qu'ils aient fini de manger caca après
après l'échauffement et le match
Christophe
tu vas pas aller pas faire un match de
final en disant j'ai envie de ta popo et
pour la dernière fois je n'ai qu'une
chose à dire
un enthousiasme pas toujours partagé par
les anciens de l'équipe de France Michel
Platini Laurent Blanc et Zinédine Zidane
ne seront pas du voyage au Qatar tout
comme Karim Benzema pas intéressé
trois comme trois étoiles Karim Benzema
est derrière ses coéquipiers tout comme
Paul Pogba qui a laissé un message voilà
je vous donne tout mon soutien beaucoup
croisent encore au retour de la lumière
ils en ont mis deux en première mi-temps
on y croit
[Musique]
on y croit les gars et comme par
enchantement comme s'ils entendaient
l'Hexagone depuis le kata les Bleus ont
tout relancé
[Applaudissements]
Griezmann quand il marque un but
il fait la célébration du pingouin
un but puis de signer Kylian Mbappe
ambiance phénoménale dans son club de
Bondy la ville où il a grandi
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui va gagner
leur place parce qu'on le sait notre
équipe de France va
à la maison
à l'issue des tirs au but et des rêves
brisées
et même des larmes il a un consolable je
voulais lui faire plaisir la défaite des
Bleus se lit sur les têtes des
supporters
[Musique]
sur les Champs-Élysées tout ça se
ressent Léo marron il devait y avoir du
monde finalement vous êtes quasiment
seul ce soir sous la pluie Léo
un peu plus fort
au soleil sous la pluie à midi ou à
minuit il y a tout ce que vous voulez
aujourd'hui
un souvenir fait date l'explosion de la
popularité de Jacques Chirac après la
première étoile des Bleus en 1998 sa
cote était montée de 18 points on est
d'abord très triste tous déçu comme
après une défaite et surtout comme ça
parce qu'on est passé si près du but et
en même temps ce que j'ai dit à tous les
joueurs un instant dans le vestiaire
c'est qu'il nous avait rendu immensément
fier et qui nous avait fait vibrer et je
pense c'est une des plus grandes une des
plus grandes finales de Coupe du monde
que nous avons tous vécu mais depuis cet
effet drapeau est à moindre riz plus 7
points pour Jacques Chirac lors de la
finale de 2006 plus un point pour
François Hollande lors de celle de
l'Euro 2016 et même moins deux points
pour Emmanuel Macron malgré la deuxième
étoile en 2018